this is a man who's done it all in the
business Stephen Stills why don't you
play some treetop flyer because I never
fire I don't do business that won't make
me smile I love my arrow painful she got
style
I'm a tree top line and I'll fly whisk
it for your most anything but girls the
bush league pilots they just can't get
the job done you got to fly down into
the canyons you don't never see the Sun
ain't no such thing as a easier
[Music]
and I fly low I'm in high demand all
right good Dean beep over the Rio Grande
and I'll blow the mesquite right up off
the bus and sell don't seem specially
when I land I'm accreta people by asking
me where you learn to fly laughing he's
over in Vietnam Jason can be a the
government told me and they told me
right stay down under the tree line you
might be you're right your time
[Music]
I'm coming home I'm running low and fast
I promised my woman
and [ __ ] is gonna be my last I get the
ship down and I make her bad and some
over walk up adhesive heesu or to make
some fast cash
[Music]
well there's things I here and there's
things I'm not I'm a smuggler and I
could get shot ain't going to die ain't
going to get caught
yes er my flying fooling an airplane I'm
just you I'm a treetop liar
[Music]